priorité à droite sont faibles et redis
j'ai du sang sunnite
stationnement interdit bonjour je les
salue françois tu va bien ça va je dois
merci caf à casimir et bien devant lui
doit même parce que si je te le disais
moi tu ne me croirait pas pourquoi c'est
si étonnant que ça bien plus encore
casimir karystos rails est il possible
de savoir ce que tu fais ouais il suffit
de me le demander
alors je te le demande qu'est ce que tu
me demandes
casimir que lis tu âge j'apprends mon
code de la route
bravo casimir mais c'est une excellente
occupation sans croit trop souvent que
le code de la route n'intéresse que les
automobilistes mais c'est pas vrai il y
a deux dents des choses très
intéressantes pour les piétons casimir
je suis très content que tu es compris
ça oui mais c'est pas en tant qu aux
piétons que le code de la route vers
haïti
que veux tu dire eh bien c'est parce que
j'ai une auto commun et une automobile
et une voiture oui c'était un cadeau de
mon oncle archibald
elle marche très bien tu veux dire la
voir oui non non non il faut que je
surveille mes ballons non je préfère ne
pas voir ça nos papilles racontent à
leur jeunesse
julie tu entendu c'est avait prévenu
mais son oncle archibald et voiliers il
faut absolument empêcher casimir de
conduire cette automobile mais comment
faire écoute c simple les enfants n'ont
pas le droit de conduire
oui mais la loi est la même pour tout le
monde mais casimir us et les armes
que veux tu dire toi là eh bien on a le
droit de conduire une automobile à 18
ans et comme les casimir us vivent
plusieurs centaines d'années ils sont
beaucoup plus longtemps enfants que les
hommes
oui j'ai compris ce que tu veux dire
bien que casimir soit loin d'être un
adulte il est plus âgé qui nous fait et
nous n'y pouvons rien en soi
bonjour kazim il quand les piétons et
que tu vois un panneau de sens interdit
dans quel sens il faut regarder pour
voir si une voiture arrive on peut je
suis d'expliquer ça sur le tableau noir
à émir regardes tu m'as voici un
carrefour
ouais voilà ouais en un carrefour
casimir d'accord ici je dessine un
passage pour piétons voilà et ici il ya
un panneau de sens interdit même chaque
côté de la rue voilà comme ça tu sais
comment c'est un panneau de sens
interdit faire au rouge avec une barbe
blanche très bien une barbe blanches
horizontales casimir de toute façon
quand tu te trouves dans une rue d'une
connaît pas avant de traverser du regard
toujours à droite et à gauche mais
admettons que du connaît cette rue et
que tu saches qu'ici il ya des panneaux
de sens interdit
ouais toi casimir qu ici et du veut
traverser la rue comme ceux ci auraient
de quel côté dois tu regardes et c'est
la question que je te pose à ce que
gémir bon je te réponds les voitures qui
viennent par ici n'ont pas le droit de
continuer puisque lé panneau de sens
interdit
la banque les voitures arrivent par ici
leur casimir toit est bien dur garde à
droite avant de traverser regarde
également à gauche on ne sait jamais je
sens mes françois et casimir très
important toujours traverser dans le
passage pour piétons - alors ça je m'en
moque complètement parce que moi je
roule en voiture
ah oui c'est vrai casimir soient
prudents quand même roule doucement je
t'en prie ne t'inquiète pas françois
olala au julie julie casimir inquiète de
plus en plus de toute façon personne ne
parviendra à l'empêcher de conduire
cette voiture si encore il connaissait
bien son code de la route on voit ça
pour ça tu n'as pas de soucis hatcher il
a travaillé toute la journée il le sait
par coeur et ce qui est sûr qu'il sera
reçue à son permis de conduire mais je
suis dit mais nous sommes idiots nous
n'avions même pas pousser à ça à quoi
mais il n'a pas son permis de conduire
il n'a donc pas le droit de conduire une
automobile oui c'est vrai ou françois
dépêche toi va l'arrêter avant qu'il ne
provoque un accident
d'accord tant pis pour les ballons je
vais vous en parler me retiens que se
passe-t-il
il faut appeler l'ambulance une
ambulance il est arrivé un accident bah
oui sinon je n'aurais pas besoin d'armée
incident alexis donc qui signale un
blessé un autre côté nous en parle en
français monsieur du ch'nord
je voulais l'enjeu sens unique à toute
vitesse
il a traversé regardons-nous mauvais
côté monsieur desjardins c'est
épouvantable julie vite rendu téléphoné
à l'hôpital pour qu'il envoie
immédiatement une ambulance casimir
conduis moi sur les guildes action vite
pourquoi veux-tu ap une ambulance qui
signe à tétouan qu'elle s'était bêtises
comme ça vite je te suis dit c'est par
là alors voilà nous y voilà
on n'y voit rien casimir mais je ne vois
rien mais la regarde
monsieur du snav a été renversé par ma
voiture c'est ça ta voiture des jouets
ah ouais j'ai jamais dit le contraire et
moi qui ai appelé l'ambulance haut
france soir
[Musique]